[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de
baffes un numéro spécial totalement
consacré aux prochaines élections
américaines qui vous savez auront lieu
le 3 novembre après une campagne
déroutante ébouriffante parfois
peut-être désespérante pour la
démocratie au moins et une campagne qui
aboutira le 3o à l'élection du nouveau
président si tant est qu'on sache le
résultat ce jour là ce qui n'est pas
tout à fait sûrs alors pour parler de de
cette élection du 3 novembre et me
porter bonjour vous êtes la porte parole
du parti démocrate vous vivez aussi dans
l'est dans les yvelines
et alors c'est très je ne sais pas
pourquoi les américains aiment les
yvelines parce que nicolas cocker
bonjour bonjour alors vous n'êtes pas du
tout démocrate
vous êtes vous êtes chargé de
responsable de coordination et du lien
avec des médias pour les républicains et
mais vous avez grandi vous dans la
vallée de chevreuse donc vous avez aussi
avec avec les yvelines et puis le
ricanement bonjour bonjour vous êtes
maître de conférences à l'université de
versailles saint quentin vous êtes un
spécialiste de la civilisation des pays
anglophones
vous avez publié plusieurs ouvrages dont
la fin du rêve américain chez odile
jacob et vous publiez vous n'êtes
diriger un nouvel ouvrage qui s'appelle
le rêve américain à l'épreuve de donald
trump dans la con dont on voit la
couverture ces deux éditions vendémiaire
qui sortit ya une quinzaine de jours et
c'est un ouvrage collectif qui fait le
bilan au fond du mandat de donald trump
à travers le prisme que serait america
dont il tait l'été le
le porter pendant sa compagne de 2016
nicolas gendry et aussi avec nous
bonjour patrice atp 68 et vous suivez de
près ces élections américaines et puis
aussi on aura aussi une interview
d'andré barkoff qui était l'auteur ya
quatre ans de trump les raisons de la
colère et qui avait prédit et qui
souhaitait d'ailleurs aussi de
l'élection de trappes et nous parlera de
ce corps des là donc il soutient alors
dubaï donne c'est une élection qui fait
trembler le monde c'est en tout cas une
élection qui nous qui nous passionne jeu
peut-être commencé avec vous et demi
pourquoi est ce qu'elle nous passionne
autant cette année cette élection sans
exagérer la position des etats-unis dans
le monde c'est quand même un enjeu un
peu mondiale qui est en train de se
jouer
je sais plus qui a dit que les états
unis étaient le pays
indispensable train pas tellement cassé
les normes et tout ce que les présidents
précédents avaient fait vis-à-vis du
reste du monde que tout le monde attend
de savoir est-ce qu'on va revenir dans
le droit chemin
ou est ce que on va continuer dans cette
cette décision totalement inédite ni et
nicolas conquérir la même question
pourquoi pourquoi ça nous passionne
autant cette élection alors forcément
comme disait ému les etats unis sont la
première puissance économique mondiale
est une vraie fascination pour tout ce
qui est importé des états unis pour le
pire parfois pour le meilleur mais
également on est dans une phase où il ya
des enjeux majeurs avec soin une
continuité ou un changement radical pour
le pire si ça venait à passer du côté
démocrate à l'idée que notre pardon
excusez moi les villes et vite
à noter qu effectivement ce qui change
considérablement par rapport aux
présidents précédents c'est que c'est la
première fois du moins de mon existence
que j'aurai un président qui n'a
déclenché aucune guerre durant son
mandat et ce qu'ils méritent d'être
quand même souligner pour pour la paix
dans le monde
essayez également des enjeux
diplomatiques de taille alors on va
parler des enjeux dans un instant sur
sur aux fossettes la façon dont on
regarde cette élection peut-être avec
avec passion avec aussi étonnement
souvent parce que c'est une des
campagnes les plus invraisemblables cons
et qu'on ait jamais vécu quel est votre
sentiment lorie kane ton ah oui à un
invraisemblable oui c'est à dire que moi
je suis les campagnes américaines depuis
96 je n'ai jamais vu un tel degré de
fascination à la limite de l'obsession
compulsive dans les médias français et
dans les médias internationaux seror
anglophone il ya une théâtralisation il
faut ajouter ça il ya la dimension les
états unis première puissance économique
première puissance militaire donc il ya
un certain nombre de dimensions comme ça
factuelle qui sont indéniables et il ya
aussi une théâtralisation le ce le cas
au vent le carreau permet de vieux faire
du clic sur les sites internet de faire
de l'audience et donc de ce point de vue
là cette dramatisation elle elle nourrit
également la dramatisation et la
dramatisation et le dire de qui et de
quoi
alors elle vient d en fait elle vient on
peut l'attribuer aux deux camps c'est à
dire que la dramatisation se nourrit des
deux camps évidemment celui qui est aux
manettes c'est donald trump
donc c'est forcément lui qui va impulser
un style contre lequel va réagir
l'opposition ça c'est faux c'est
obligatoire de la même manière que quand
obama était au pouvoir
c'est lui qui a impulsé une politique
qui suscitaient les mois par exemple du
tea party aux états unis donc il ya
toujours une position qui est la
position de celui qui est au pouvoir il
faut pas oublier que celui qui est au
pouvoir partage le pouvoir avec le
congrès et que le congrès c'est aussi un
sénat qui est aux mains des républicains
alors que la chambre est aux mains des
démocrates au delà on a des sources de
tensions à l'intérieur même du pouvoir
avec en plus de tout ça le feuilleton de
la cour suprême qui s'ajouté donc là on
a là le triangle de la séparation des
pouvoirs et le style de trump de toute
façon et là personne ne s'en cache et
trucks le premier le style de trouver là
également pour faire de la dramatisation
trump vient de la télé donc trompés par
les deux treuils donc tout ça nourrit de
toutes façons de l'indignation ce qui
est de bonne guerre et tout ça nourrit
non question pour emi pour nicolas quand
on est aussi loin de son pays
quant à cette double nationalité franco
américaine comment on vit justement ce
scrutin depuis la france depuis les
yvelines pour pour tous les deux comment
vis tu cette élection évidemment grâce à
internet en vie
enfin minute par minute c'est vrai qu'on
est un peu en décalé donc
malheureusement pour nous ça veut dire
qu'on ne dort pas beaucoup en ce moment
on se réveille tôt le matin on se
réveille tôt le matin en branchant
téléphone et on se dit mais qu'est ce
qu'il a encore dit cette nuit mais
qu'est ce qui va se passer aujourd'hui
dans l'immédiat et évidemment j'ai
encore de la famille et beaucoup d'amis
aux états unis donc je vois aussi les
choses à travers eux et ce qu'ils vivent
actuellement
ma soeur est en floride par exemple elle
n'est quasiment pas sortie de chez elle
depuis le mois de mars avec le co vide
donc c'est vraiment c'est hors
hâtivement facile en fait de rester au
courant ni colle courant de ce qui se
passe nicolas cocker sur sur ce ça fait
cette façon que vous vivez des élections
effectivement par internet et via les
réseaux c'est d'ailleurs là dessus que
la campagne se joue beaucoup
on est associé à ce qui se passe aux
etats unis est également donc avec ces
communautés de républicains ou
éventuellement démocrate parfois on est
qui vivent à l'étranger on est assez
associés on vit sa part par passion on
n'est qu'à 9 millions à vivre en dehors
des états unis donc ça représente un
poids significatif et c'est un vote qui
sera vraiment crucial pour les sinus que
dans l'ag un mot puis après on va passer
quand même au jour j'ai bien sûr le sur
le co vide de dante est atteinte trump
voilà un homme qui a 74 ans qui est en
surpoids qui est atteint de de ce virus
dont on dit qu'il est très mauvais pour
les gens qui sont dans cette situation
physique est là il fait deux meetings
par jour quelques jours après avoir été
atteint
comment ils on a beaucoup parlé de fake
12 selon vous il a vraiment le virus ou
pas je n'ai aucun moyen de vous répondre
je pense que c'est aussi probable que
tout ça a été un chaud que ce qu'il a
vraiment eu
et comme il a bénéficié d'un cocktail de
médicaments qui n'est disponible à
personne d'autre aux états unis qui
paraît-il des panneaux pour soi des
pluies boeuf en croûte ou payés par le
contribuable d'ailleurs lui il n'avait
pas sorti
un kopeck de sa poche alors que les
pauvres américains qui n'ont plus de
couverture médicale est d'ailleurs 30
essaie actuellement de retirer
l'assurance maladie à 20 millions
d'américains oui eux il fait des
milliers de dollars pour se faire
soigner même des tests peuvent coûter
très cher donc il ya vraiment une
injustice par rapport à son traitement
nicolas vous pensez que c'est un
surhomme qui a surmonté le virus ça
indéniablement mais il ya des gens très
bien moi même je suis passé à faire cet
épisode là et on l'a sûrement très bien
on pense également évidemment toutes les
victimes qui sont une des victimes est
effectivement malheureuse pour lequel on
à la peine pour leurs familles pour
leurs amis en dehors de ça il faut noter
qu' il ya eu une politique qui était un
peu différente
une approche différente le port du
masque on n'était pas systématique
il avait une approche où il faisait
tester tous les membres du staff de
l'équipe de trappes quotidiennement je
noterai juste que notre ami démocrate
ici fort fort tendance à dénoncer les
polémiques des fakes news des théories
complotistes mais qu'elle a dénoncé le
diagnostic du président entre hommes
s'arrêtent quand même m'en donne une
idée assez farfelue donc je dirai pas
plus loin d'oran traitement le
traitement visa généralité et de fait de
montrer que le président trump a fait
confiance à la médecine et au
développement des traitements et que lui
même et j'ai pu
il pu en bénéficier à leur rendre
disponible à l'ensemble des américains
puis par la suite m'exporter c'est un
vrai message qui doit donner confiance
on est vraiment dans l'exemplarité du
chef et d'avoir terrassé ce virus-là en
trois jours cet exceptionnel et qu'il
ait pu reprendre la voie des meetings et
continuer sur cette dynamique de
campagne à neuf jours de l'élection
alors qu'au même moment le candidat by
donne lui donne un jeune de
l'accompagner un arrêt de toutes ses
apparitions
on est vraiment dans une approche tout à
fait différente et américains choisir
que là vous savez parfaitement que c'est
archi-faux qu'abidal sort tous les jours
il fait des meetings aussi mais en
distance et que depuis trente ans par
que trump a repris ses meetings il y a
des 10
zen de gens infectés par le cos vide qui
ont assisté à ses meetings
donc il se met tous ensemble sans
distanciation sans masque il est logique
qu'ils tombent malades
le week-end tout juste je vous demande
pas s'il est apte à ou battant mais
c'est c'est très symptomatique c'est à
dire que on peut douter de tout dans
cette campagne a de toute façon on en
est on en est arrivé à un point où les
gens ne se parlent plus les gens' accuse
de tous les maux tout le monde doute
d'absolument tout à ce qu'il a us qu'il
n'a pas eu bon est ce que c'est un coup
tordu ou est ce qu'il a vraiment eu et
avec le traitement qu'il a eu bon on
aurait pu imaginer que il soit un petit
peu patraque
mais je connais des gens qui s'en sont
rétablis en une petite semaine et hop
c'est reparti et je connais des gens qui
ont entraîné sa notamment le des gens
qu'ils ont eu plus tôt en mars
visiblement ce n'était plus virulents en
mars et qui ont toujours des séquelles
donc c'est vrai que c'est on réagit pas
tous de la même façon on n'est pas tous
soignés de la même façon on aurait pu
imaginer qu'ils soient plus patrick sur
la fin de la campagne
il ne l'est pas on aurait pu imaginer
également qu' il soit d'abord dopée par
par la cortisone et corticoïdes qui
prenait assez haute dose au départ est
qu après alors on s'est tous si on
appris du soleil près de ce genre de
trucs
au début on est à fond et puis au bout
de deux trois jours quand on arrête là
celui pas de fous là ça redescend et
l'immunité on prend un coup donc on
aurait pu aussi imaginer qu'il y ait un
coup de moins bien
pour l'instant c'est pas le cas la
compagnie suit son cours des des deux
côtés avec les acteurs principaux est ce
qu'on appelle des sols
ce regain c'est à dire des gens qui font
campagne pour le principal exemple qu'on
a vu ces derniers temps c'est au mamac
et campagne pour spider par exemple
l'ags la campagne n'est pas limitée aux
deux prétendants et au rock
il ya des campagnes parallèle qui se
dirait qu'ils se déroulent un petit peu
partout et qui se déroulent pas de là
forcément de la même façon c'est à dire
que ce qu'on attend ça pas voir au
niveau démocrate c'est vraiment très
important c'est que il ya un mouvement
de la base par des associations qui sont
nés il ya assez peu de temps comme
renault samsung qui est une association
qui est pas seulement de porte à porte
mais qui est une association qui a
engagé des moyens pour que les gens se
présentent également c'est un autre
aspect de la démocratisation et c'est
intéressant donc le sur le porte-à-porte
les républicains sont très forts donc
c'est vraiment de la mobilisation au
niveau de la rue et donc ça c'est
vraiment très important c'est ce qui
marche le mieux
ça marche mieux que les pubs à la télé
ou des choses sur internet
c'est vraiment le face à face et les
démocrates le fond aussi mais font aussi
se présenter des gens et là on note
beaucoup plus de candidats que quatre
ans et des candidats avec des profils
plus variés ça c'est factuel alors on va
passer premier chapiteau au cours de
cette émission c'est sont les enjeux de
l'élection alors d'abord quel est l'état
d'esprit qui règne aujourd'hui aux
etats-unis est-ce que c'est une amérique
apaisé ou qui cherchent la paix ce bourg
peut-être avec l'élection de baden où
est ce que s'y tenait mais qui n'a
jamais été autant divisée qu'elle ne
l'est aujourd'hui je pense que
l'amérique est très très divisée
on a toujours été un peu 48 48% fin n'y
a jamais eu de grand écart entre les
entre les deux camps et c'est vrai qu'il
ya plutôt que de quant aux états unis
par rapport à la france qui en plus
plutôt d'autres tendances mais je dirais
surtout que les américains sont
aujourd'hui épuisés ils n'en peuvent
plus de ce chaos de justement tous les
matins met la télé et voir mais
qu'est-ce qu'il a encore dit qu'est ce
qu'il a encore fait ils veulent du calme
et ils veulent un retour à la normalité
et joe biden incarne quelque part se
calme le fait qu'ils soient à peser à
91-78 aussi peut-être honorant 78 tu ne
vieillis sol va les avoir il les aura le
jeu me convient pas
s'il prend ses fonctions c'est vrai que
oui on a l'impression quand même d'une
amérique un peu fatigué nicolas conc'air
par exemple et lorenzo évidemment je
suis assez surpris quatre amis
démocrates nous parle d'ordre car c'est
vraiment un mot que brydon naïve à peine
à prononcer le law order qui est
vraiment un pilier sur lequel trump fait
campagne pour arriver à rétablir
voilà des centres villes les apaisé
après qu'ils aient ces cinq mois
d'émeutes dont on reparlera sûrement
mais des villes qui ont été livrés en
pâture et tout a été instrumentalisé par
des gouverneurs démocrates qui qui
instrumentalisent du fait de société ou
une crise sanitaire pour chercher à
porter atteinte à trump et au pays à la
mairie comme toi dans son intégralité
donc il ya différentes manières et que
ça soit des recours à linkin chemin pour
des motifs vraiment vraiment léger
lissieu on à la trouver donc il ya
vraiment une fatigue de cette tendance
d'entraver la marche du pays par les par
la parti démocrate et sa frange la plus
extrême dont il donne les cas la façade
ya évidemment des enjeux internationaux
des enjeux écologiques bailon a dit
qu'il reviendrait dans les accords de
paris par exemple s'il était élu mais en
ce qui concerne l'amérique lors
caneton vous rappelez dans votre livre
donc le rêve américain à l'épreuve de
donald trump au fond au-delà des mesures
dont on a beaucoup parlé c'est à dire le
mur contre l'immigration mexicaine
l'idée de cette amérique d'abord c'était
de renouer avec une sorte de nostalgie
celle de l'amérique des années 50
l'amérique d'eisenhower l'amérique avant
qu'elle ne soit un peu humilié comme
l'avait été avec carter parlait parlait
par les iraniens
alors évidemment c'est une nostalgie qui
ne concerne pas tous les américains du
concept des américains blancs
essentiellement non oui parce que les
américains ont quelque chose à regretter
enfin les américains blancs en quelque
chose éventuellement a regretté dans les
années 50 mais c'est quelque chose qu'on
sait une nostalgie qu'on retrouve
également au temps dans le camp entre
hommes que dans le camp sanders est à
dire l'amérique prospère un qui
pensaient que la grande dépression était
quelque chose qui était peut-être
tellement totalement dépassé et que en
fait maintenant on avait atteint une
espèce de millénium les mille ans de
bonheur et il y aurait plus de
dépressions généralement c'est comme
quand on est dans une relation amoureuse
heureuse on a toujours l'impression que
ça y est c'est pour toujours et la
prospérité c'est toujours la même chose
en fait un truand passion que ça y est
c'est fini c'est pour toujours
donc ces années 50 c'était des années où
les lendemains chanter et où n'importe
qui en sortant du lycée vous pouvez
avoir un job stable et rémunérateur l
usine ford temps face comme papa et de
ce point de vue là il n'y a pas
d'angoissé
c'est tout ça c'est arrivé dans les
années par les années 70 en revanche
pour les noirs évidemment les années 50
c'est les années de la ségrégation
c'est la fin de la ségrégation m'enfin
ça reste quand même des années qu'on ne
regrette pas particulièrement et pour
les hispaniques et les asiatiques là
c'est encore autre chose puisque c'est
des années où il n'était pas aux états
unis et ils étaient dans des pays qu'ils
ont fui ou quittez donc qui avait pas
grand chose à regretter
donc c'est pour ça que la nostalgie elle
s'applique pas à tout le monde de la
même façon et pour certains groupes 1 ne
s'applique pas du tout parce que la
seule chose
la seule aspiration finalement aller
elle est devancée
c'est un avenir à construire mais alors
est ce que résume évidemment mais est ce
qu'à votre sens alors que vous abordez
le plein de clubs tous les tous les
domaines un don dont ce livre est abordé
par des spécialistes mais est ce que au
fond vous dirais que deux trains pas été
à la hauteur de ce rêve américain qu'il
préférait il prétendait défendre
la réponse allait très simple vous
demandé à amy pourtant elle va vous dire
non vous demandez à nicolas il va vous
dire oui et l'amérique est très divisée
de ce point de vue là de du point de vue
des républicains oui c'est mission
accomplie la ilaha illa il a tenu ses
promesses un premier skate son slogan du
point de vue des démocrates le compte
n'y est pas et d'une certaine manière il
a détruit les différentes composantes
qui composent le rêve américain pour les
démocrates l'opinion est complètement
divisé ce qui n'était pas forcément le
cas avant ça c'est beaucoup accentué au
début des années 2000 il y avait un
livre sur la polarisation qu on utilise
beaucoup à l'université parce qu'il est
petit court et très bien documenté qui
explique que en gros la pop la
polarisation c'était d'abord un
phénomène qui concernait les élites
politiques
les commentateurs les partisans et c est
qu en réalité l'opinion était beaucoup
moins polarisé qu'on voulait bien le
dire est en réalité maintenant l'opinion
est devenu beaucoup plus polarisé parce
que notamment par les réseaux sociaux il
ya une sorte de ruissellement non pas
économique mais idéologique d'une
certaine manière et les positions sont
beaucoup plus tranchées qu'elles l'ont
été et ça ça se passe en l'espace de
quinze d'une quinzaine d'années donc
c'est un changement majeur de dents dans
la structuration de l'opinion américaine
justement c'est vrai que je veux poser
la question à vous aimer porter et à
nicolas coquet je me suis accueillie en
2016 quand il a été élu tout le monde
disait oui d'accord
enfin il va pas appliquer ce qu'il a dit
il va pas faire le mur il va pas faire d
or il a quand même tenu ses promesses
alors parlons justement du mur la
frontière avec le mexique
c'est 3200 km tron a promis il a donné
comme objectif il a fait faire à peu
près un tiers 1200 kg mais vous savez
combien de mur
a été construit huit kilomètres de
nouveau mur a été construit depuis
quatre ans ils ont remplacé 415 km qui
étaient déjà là par une nouvelle
barrière 415 sur 3000 de on est loin du
compte dont il n'a tenu aucune promesse
la seule promesse qu'il a tenue et en
fait la seule le seul vrai réussite si
je puis dire de trains pendant son
mandat
c'était de baisser de façon
spectaculaire les impôts pour les plus
riches un mille milliards et demi pour
les pour les grandes entreprises comme
amazon qui aujourd'hui pzero de la
d'impôts alors qu'ils gagnent des
milliards en bénéfices donc en fait il a
il a plongé l'économie dans une
récession le pib a baissé de 30% et ils
n'arrêtent pas de dire j'avais le
meilleur économie du monde avant ghrib
qui avait de covin c'était déjà pas le
camp est de toute façon peut pas faire
semblant que le coc vite n'existe pas il
y toujours dans cette histoire de pensée
magique trump sa valise pas ça va
disparaître ça sera un miracle et et
tous les jours les chiffres montrent est
monté au tous les jours en brise des
records absolument terrifiant du nombre
de cas et de nombre de décès nicolas
conquérir l'or sur le sur le mandat de
donald trump
vous pensez qu'il vous faut réaliser ce
qu'il avait promis
absolument comme le disait les promesses
kate
on est vraiment dans la sincérité de se
tenir aux engagements qui ont été pris
et qui sont qui sont réalisés je
reviendrai pas sur le chiffre concernant
le mur qui sont bien plus importants que
ce que dit amy mais je les tiens à votre
disposition
en revanche pour ce qui va être des
taxes cote dont qui est vraiment quelque
chose de significatif une réforme
fiscale qui a contribué à diminuer
significativement les impôts ça s'est
répercuté sur absolument tout le monde
tous les foyers ont vu lors lors leur
fiche de paie monter leurs placements
for one mais qu'est vraiment se
valoriser donc c'est vraiment vraiment
des impacts très significatifs et ça a
vraiment stimuler l'emploi
je pense que
henneton abondera dans mon sens de dire
que cette réduction de la bureaucratie
est vraiment stimulé à favoriser
l'emploi booster l'économie et que là
malgré un épisode tragique de lune crise
une crise sanitaire sans précédent
les cinq plus de 50% des emplois qui ont
été supprimés ont déjà été recréée en
moins de six mois depuis mars
en tant qu'homme de 11 millions
d'emplois s'ils ont déjà été recréés
c'est vraiment une performance vraiment
à souligner on voit bien l'opposition
entre les deux un mot parce qu'on va
passer ensuite aux règles de cette
élection il faut les explique louis
loric en fait bon si moi je suis pas
partisan donc j'ai je suis d'accord je
suis d'accord avec les chercheurs les
kilométrages de muret les murs qui était
pas construit qui a été construit après
c'était notamment par de l'argent privé
il ya une partie qui s'est écroulé dans
le rio grande et ça fait quand même un
peu moi mais effet le sur l'économie il
faut quand même dire dire une chose
c'est que l'économie est en récession à
cause du coc vis de l'économie de trump
était assez florissante mais elle était
florissante comme l'était celle d'obama
est ce qu'on voyait en fait entre la fin
du mandat d'obama et disons novembre
décembre 2010 et décembre 2019
disons pour simplifier c'est que
l'économie de trump était dans la
continuité absolue ni plus ni moins de
l'économie d'obama que la bourse monte
parce qu'elle montait déjà sous obama
que les créations d'emplois c'est
peut-être la seule différence commencé à
se tasser c'est à dire qu'il ya eu moins
en global de création d'emplois sous
trump que dans le deuxième mandat
d'obama ça qu'il y avait un
infléchissement tout simplement ce
n'était pas une question de pas mal de
trucs qu'on était en fin de cycle
économique en revanche ce qu'il ya c'est
que qu'on regarde pas trop quand on
regarde juste les chiffres mais quand on
regarde un peu sous le capot le secteur
manufacturier alors la d2 tout le monde
s'endort parties savent le secteur
manufacturier qui était quand même le
coeur de cible de deux trains étaient en
récession pendant cinq mois d'affilée
donc c'est à dire en récession c'est
l'indicé s m dans la rose pelt en
particulier donc là son programme
économique en gros quand on regarde la
big picture oui ça allait mieux quand on
regarde l'électorat qu'il
les protégés ça n'allait pas mieux donc
ça dépend toujours de ce qu'on regarde
et vois là et après il ya un certain
nombre de choses qu'il faut un petit peu
nuancé sur notamment sur les questions
sur les questions économiques
alors on va évidemment et et toute cette
gestion du monde attrape va peser
probablement sur l'élection d' or ce
qu'on appelle notamment les swing states
mais on va d'abord rappeler qu'elles
sont des avec des coloris les règles de
cette élection américaine
parfois un peu compliqué pour nous op 1
[Musique]
nicolas rappeler d'où voilà on vote
d'abord pour des grands électeurs c'est
ça effectivement les citoyens américains
ont toutefois bien sûr de voter entre
joe biden ou donald trump mais il vote
en fait pour 538 grands électeurs chaque
état a un nombre de grands électeurs qui
est proportionnel au nombre d'habitants
par exemple l'état de californie
rapporte 55 grands électeurs 38 pour
l'état du texas ou encore 20 pour
l'illinois
l'objectif pour chaque candidat en fait
c'est d'obtenir suffisamment d'état pour
décrocher 270 grands électeurs et c'est
ce qui explique parfois que le candidat
qui obtient le plus de voix n'est pas
forcément élue ça a été le cas en 2016
hillary clinton avait obtenu plus de
voix mais n'avait pas été élu parce que
donald trump avait dépassé le nombre de
grands électeurs 270 morts
contre bush en 2001 me semble-t-il alors
à l'heure actuelle il ya plus de 50
millions d'américains japon ont déjà
voté alors pourquoi c'est la
particularité un des états unis le vote
est anticipée soit par correspondance
comme pour les américains qui vivent à
l'étranger notamment aux abonnés 22
septembre
nicolas vous avez voté ok aussi
donc voilà fois par correspondance pour
les américains qui vivent à l'étranger
mais aussi pour les américains qui
vivent aux états unis où soit
directement dans les bureaux de vote
parce qu'en fait voilà c'est ça le trump
a déjà voté donc en floride
il ya des bureaux de vote qui sont
ouverts depuis le 18 septembre
c'est le cas du minnesota de la virginie
où du wyoming et même situation dans le
colorado en floride ou en alaska qui
essaient des bureaux qui sont ouverts
depuis le 19 octobre et alors on va le
voir sur les images donc émis vous avez
déjà voté avec une amie que vous avez
reçu une amie qui est originaire et qui
votent dans l'état de new york est en
fait la particularité pour les
américains qui vivent à l'étranger c'est
que chaque état à sa procédure de vote
d'où vous aimez vous avez voté pour la
première fois parce que j'avais un peu
peur de la poste
j'ai toujours voté par correspondance
enfin il ya une vingtaine d'états qui
permettent aux gens de voter soit par
e-mail soit directement sur un site
internet
peut-être une trentaine et une vingtaine
où vous êtes obligé de renvoyer votre
bulletin par la poste
parce qu'ils veulent une signature
originale il ya cinq étapes dans la
floride le mien qui vous permettent de
voter par fax donc pour la première fois
j'ai voté par fax parce que je ne
faisais pas vraiment confiance à la
poste alors que sainté c'est de ralentir
la poste justement pour ralentir des
votes
comment ça se passe chez vous nicolas
dans le minnesota
donc là en l'occurence j'ai pu voter par
correspondance et donc j'ai envoyé mon
bulletin
on dirait qu'ils sont des états unis
malgré le fait que ce soit une
possibilité quand même savoir que c'est
le moyen le canal par lequel il ya le
plus de pertes en ligne le traitement de
ces bulletins à ses gars régulièrement
et c'est pour ça qu'il faut le limiter
vraiment à les câbles et les plus
spécifiques et pas le généraliser
aucunement de nombreux américains bien
évidemment qui vote par correspondance
du fait de la situation sanitaire
c'est une terre qui fait qu'il ya
peut-être moins d'américains qui vont
aller le même jour voté dans les autre
raison pour laquelle tant de gens déjà
voté les gens ont compris que les
républicains mettait en place des tas de
mesures pour essayer justement de faire
en sorte qu'ils votent moins de leur
faire peur de leur dire ça va pas
compter valoir la fraude etc
donc les gens concernés sont dit moi je
vais pas attendre le dernier jour
peut-être que ce jour-là il pleuvra il
neigera il y aura un ouragan en floride
en est encore en pleine pleine saison
donc je vais voter maintenant comme ça
ça y est c'est fait j'ai pu y penser
et comme ça ils peuvent pas m'empêcher
de voter nous l'apprécions d'ailleurs
qui est une mobilisation assez forte un
des électeurs pour cette élection
peut-être plus fort que jamais il ya eu
130 millions de votants 2016 là je pense
qu'on va aller vers les 150 millions
voire les 160 millions ce qui serait
historique jeunes lorie kane dont il ya
des historiens ou des politologues
américains qui cote est justement le
mode de vote de deux pour l'élection
américaine présidentielle je lisais
notamment un historien qui expliquait
que le nombre de grands électeurs ne
dépend pas seulement de la population
telle qu elle est l été il a été fondé
sur le nouveau si on comptait aussi le
nombre d'esclaves qui bien qu'il n'ait
pas le droit de vote
agrandissez ou amoindris c'est la
population et donc sa conclusion est dit
sur faut ce vote pour les grands
électeurs c'est un héritage de
l'esclavagisme et beaucoup de d'amérique
out chercheurs américains ou de
d'observateurs pensent qu'il faudrait
revenir un vote loue celui qui a le plus
de voix au numérique et élus et tous les
grands électeurs soit obligé de voter
pour celui qui aurait le plus de voix
vous pensez quoi ces contestations du
mode de vote américain
alors bon il ya plusieurs ya plusieurs
dossiers l'attend il ya un premier point
qu'il faut jamais oublier c'est que les
états unis sont un pays fédéral il ya 50
états et donc le collège électoral est
là pour refléter la diversité des 50
états mais après il ya ce qu'on en fait
c'est à dire qu'on pourrait très bien
imaginer que le problème n'est pas le
collège électoral mais le fait que le
vainqueur d'un état prend tous les
grands électeurs on pourrait imaginer
qu'il ait une répartition différente à
la proportionnelle par exemple je gagne
60 % de l'état de californie
je prends 60% de ces grands électeurs
après dans les états où il ya trois
grands électeurs c'est plus compliqué
parce que c'est plus compliqué de
découpe et c soit 3,0 soit 2,1 soit un
vélo soit 0,3 donc là c'est plus
compliqué on pourrait aussi penser à
faire une répartition qui soit plus
proportionnelle se dit que c'est
proportionnel la population c'est pas
forcément vrai c'est proportionnel sans
être proportionnelle dans la mesure où
les certains états très peuplés ont deux
sénateurs comme tous les états y compris
les états très peuplée parce que ça ne
représente pas la population et ils ont
un seul représentant
donc c'est à dire que en réalité la la
proportionnalité elle est fausse et les
états très blanc entre ruraux et
montagnards etc sont sur représentés par
rapport à des états très peuplées comme
new york du new jersey floride et c'est
donc là de ce point de vue là il ya un
problème au niveau de la représentation
mais l'histoire de l'exclavage ça
remonte à justement quand il y avait des
esclavages aujourd'hui n'y a pas d'
esclavage jusqu'à preuve du contraire et
donc de ce point de vue là c'est
seulement l'addition du nombre de
sénateurs deux par état pour tout le
monde et du nom de représentants qui est
là en réalité proportionnel à la
population donc cette histoire d'
esclavage ça n'a plus vraiment sens
après je voudrais apporter une dernière
précision sur le fait que trump a perdu
le vote populaire mais pas le collège
électoral
c'est un peu une illusion d'optique
c'est vrai quand on prend les chiffres
globaux quand on regarde les chiffres de
la californie hillary clinton à 4
millions de voix d'avancé
si on enlève ça en réalité donc ça veut
dire que quels et une voix d'avancé en
californie 4 millions de voix d'avancé
elle empoche la mise en cause tout le
monde si on enlève la californie la
marge californie trump à un million et
demi de voix d'avancé sur les quarante
neuf autres états donc c'est le problème
des formes humaines le problème j'en
reviens à ce que je disais tout à
l'heure le problème c'est will take off
c'est à dire c'est le fait que je gagne
l'état d'une voix aux 2 4 millions de
voix c'est pareil donc c'est à dire
qu'il ya 4 millions de voix qui sont
perdus pour les démocrates en californie
mais quand on regarde les 40%
républicain qui votent en californie
alors voilà compte pas non plus donc là
il ya un problème qui est de recyclage
des voix il ya beaucoup de voix
énormément de foi qui nous comparer
c'est pour ça que vous disiez sur les
états clés c'est fondamental on a 330
millions d'habitants et comme disait
émis entre 130 et 150 millions
d'électeurs en fonction des des années
est en réalité seuls les électeurs d'à
peu près six états comptent alors que
justement on va on va savoir où se joue
l'élection c'est sûr des fameuses swing
states où se joue cette élection de 2020
[Musique]
alors on peut peut-être voir 2 2 cartes
qui sont les cartes des élections de
la réélection d'obama et l'élection de
2016 c'est à dire l'élection de deux
trains vu de loin comme ça on n'a pas
l'impression que ça chauffe beaucoup
d'ailleurs un cel sont assez semblables
ces cartes indiquant alors finalement
oui parce que donc en 2012 parmi les
fameux swing states remporté par barack
obama
il y avait des tas de floride de l'ohio
de la pennsylvanie delà johan michigan
donc c'est des états qui sont
traditionnellement indécis qui sont
situés plutôt au nord est des états unis
autour des grands lacs est à la limite
de l'entrée vers le midwest et du coup
donc ces états sont vraiment déterminant
et d'ailleurs on va le voir
sur la carte 2016 donald trump a
remporté ses états donc l'iowa le
wisconsin le michigan l'ohio la
pennsylvanie et la floride
et c'est devenu rouge donc on voit que
barack obama grâce à ces états a pu
remporter le scrutin en 2012
et finalement c'est ce qui fait basculer
le scrutin de 2016 en faveur de donald
trump et donc donc finalement en fait
barack obama avait remporté en 2006 et
trois victoires c'est 60 grands
électeurs dans les états que j'ai cités
et donc c'est ce qui fait la différence
et c'est ce que disait donc lorie kane
temps ont finalement l'oryx et des états
qui sont depuis quand on peut dater
finalement c'est que ces états sont
déterminants dans ce scrutin
présidentiel très simplement la floride
ça fait des années que en gros les
élections dépend plus ou moins de la
floride l'ohio avait sa petite période
de maintenant et loyaux quand même
plutôt pour républicain khamsa les
sondages actuellement sont plus mitigés
mais enfin on peut laisser le loyaux aux
républicains en revanche les états de
haut des grands lacs with council
michigan pennsylvanie sont des états
démocrate ce sont des états qui sont
profondément démocrate il ya un petit
bémol sur le web consignes qui a eu un
refus d'un républicain comme gouverneur
très républicain et ce sont des taxes
sont très divisés en fait il ya une
rupture entre ville et campagne qui est
assez fondamentale donc il ya une
géographie à l'intérieur de ces états là
mais globalement c'est des états qui
n'avaient pas voté républicain depuis
les années 80 depuis reagan en gros 84
et 88 donc pour les pour les 3es qui se
sont jouées a très très peu de voix
c'est à dire qu'ils sont pas des étapes
clés dans le sens où historiquement ce
sont toujours les démocrates qui les
emporte
mais ce sont des états qui ont été
déterminants en 2016 qui en 2018 sont
part repassé largement du côté des
démocrates pour les élections des
exceptions pour le gouverneur et le
sénat et qui pour l'instant dans les
sondages sont assez nettement du côté
des démocrates mais le sondage étant un
instrument de mesure assez
les limites et finalement on ne sait pas
si par exemple en pennsylvanie on n'a
pas des poches notamment dans l'ouest de
la pennsylvanie où on ne voit pas dans
le sondage des bas des postes électorat
aux républicains qui pourrait faire
basculer puisque pour 77 mille électeurs
au total on a fait basculer trois étapes
michigan s'est dit mille électeurs c'est
à dire qu'il n'a de 5000 qui changent de
côté ça fait basculer lll et l'élection
c'est rien d'ailleurs si on prend la
carte on a une terre d élection depuis
depuis l'élection de kennedy en 1960 on
voit bien que ça se joue à rien parce
que ça peut devenir absolument tout
rouge comme sur la réélection de nixon
qui a d'ailleurs été réélu avec a gagné
presque tous les états et son mandat
doit durer deux ans ce qui est peu lors
des élections de reagan aussi c'est tout
rouge de l'élection de george bush père
et puis après donc on voit bien que ça
se joue à très peu de voix quoi donc
dans quelques états qui peuvent passer
basculer d'un côté ou de l'autre qu'est
la question c'est combien d'états sont
en balance parce que par exemple la
réélection de bill clinton a été très
très large alors que son élection 92 a
été plus serré aussi c'est une
configuration à trois l'élection de 2000
est historiquement serré puisque ça
s'est joué à 500 voix en floride
donc ça va dépendre les élections de
révéler les scrutins de réélection
généralement sont beaucoup moins serré
la seule exception étant de george bush
père en 92 qui a perdu c'est le dernier
ces derniers présidents à avoir perdu
pour sa réélection normalement les
sondages devrait être nettement plus
favorable à trappes dans une
configuration de réélection on devrait
pas être avec un président qui est
derrière ces c'est du jamais vu on a vu
ça avec on a vu ça avec bush d'ailleurs
il ya ya
là encore des observateurs qui conteste
toujours ce système américain en disant
finalement puisque ça se joue dans un
nombre réduit d'états cette élection ça
oblige les candidats et peut-être les
présidents à se préoccuper sur toutes
ces états là et par exemple ici que le
fait que train c'est pas du tout
préoccupé de l'état de new york qui
était terriblement touchés par la par
l'aco vide parce qu'il sait de toute
façon de dire que ça va voter démocrate
donc c'est vrai que c'est un système un
peu pervers d'une certaine façon c'est
un système très étrange qui a ses
racines justement dans l'histoire parce
qu'au début les grands électeurs étaient
non seulement des hommes blancs mais des
hommes possédant des terrains des terres
et ça c'est un rapport en fait avec la
date où on vote pourquoi en date
pourquoi on vote le 1er mardi après le
premier lundi en novembre parce qu'à
l'époque c'était des agriculteurs donc
novembre la récolte était terminé il
n'avait pas encore implanté le dimanche
ils étaient à l'église le lundi faisait
leur compte donc le mar vive et comme il
devait pour certains voyages est assez
loin pour aller voter
ça leur donne et 720 et le temps de
revenir pour s'occuper de leurs affaires
mais c'est vrai que ce scrutin est un
vestige de l'histoire les hommes noirs
qui ont compté pour 3 5e dan sommes à
une époque
évidemment les femmes qui n'ont pu voter
en qu'en 1920 et c'est le seul scrutin
aux états unis où on veut ainsi je veux
dire les gouverneurs les sénateurs les
représentants les maires les shérifs les
u11 et un vote direct pourquoi est-ce
qu'on a ce vote indirects parce que
c'est inscrit dans la constitution et
pour l'enlever il faut je pense 75% des
voix au congrès et trois quarts des
états qui décident de l'abolir
ça n'arrivera jamais c'est d'ailleurs
partie
c'est juste parce que c'est au niveau au
dessus c'est normal qu'au niveau d'un
état où votent de manière directe mais
au niveau au dessus des états quand il
ya plusieurs errent ensemble c'est là
qu'on est dans un système fédéral c'est
comme si on avait dix ont une élection
au niveau d'un état européen et au
niveau de l'union européenne
c'est à cause du système général patrice
d'ailleurs par rapport à ce que vous
disiez sur le candidat des candidats qui
insiste sur la campagne dans certains
états ont la vue ce week-end donald
trump et et en caroline du nord dans
l'ohio et au new hampshire 3,3 meeting
sur une journée on peut citer aller les
états où ça va se jouer à la floride
évidemment parler la caroline du nord la
pennsylvanie luis comme sin l'arizona le
mussig en l'iowa l'ohio la géorgie le
texas
peut-être de texas enfin ça serait une
surprise si ça passerait aux démocrates
enfin voilà les états qui peuvent faire
jouer nicolas conc'air justement je
voudrais qu'on revienne sur eux vous
êtes du minnesota ces deux là où il ya
eu la fête george sound qui était
peut-être aussi un tournant dans cette
campagne avec l'arrivée des black light
matters vous vous espérer secrètement ou
pas secrètement d'ailleurs publiquement
que le minnesota justement pas des
démocrates aux républicains et pour
quelle raison il pourrait se passer donc
bruce pour situer le minnesota c'est un
état du midwest
donc c'est un état vraiment pu tourner
son agriculture
souvent décrié pour différentes raisons
mais donc le minnesota est considéré par
beaucoup de démocrates qui sont de
californie de new york comme faisant
partie des fly over states c'est
vraiment comme on appellerait
l'équivalent de la france périphérique
cc et a donc fait que survoler sans
vraiment s'attacher et donc voilà
effectivement période électorale on leur
donne un peu d'intérêt mais de fait sont
un peu voilà vraiment donc dans ce
milieu est là il y a eu effectivement ce
tragique incident de la décès de georges
fleuve en mai dernier qui par la suite
de star a donné lieu à un chaos
généralisé d'abord à home il ya police
dans la capitale des sites à mai
après répandue dans beaucoup de villes
américaines est essentiellement des
villes gérées par des mères démocrate ou
dans des états a tenu par des
gouverneurs démocrates et qui ont
vraiment instrumentaliser ce à la
mémoire de ce pauvre homme pour laisser
libre cours à leur bras armé idéologique
que son des black dice matters et les
antifas qui ont saccagé et tous les
centres villes occasionnant des dégâts
monstrueux chiffrant en milliards
mais également en créant un climat
vraiment de quasiment guerre civile
raciale ou on essentialise la couleur de
peau va vraiment on est allé aux autres
posé aux antipodes des enseignements qui
avait livré le très grand au révérend
martin luther king ou ont jugé d'abord
le caractère d'une personne plutôt que
sa couleur de peau donc j'ai vraiment dû
démocrates se sont vraiment pris les
pieds dans les franges les plus extrêmes
du partira de démocrates notamment donc
une représentante qui est au minnesota
qui ilan m'a pas mal de casseroles
derrière elle mais voilà donc tous ces
éléments là et le fait que les
républicains ont gagné un siège de plus
donc là chez des représentants
conduisent à une possible possible
victoire des républicains ce qui serait
vraiment un beau gage de confiance dans
le président est aussi comme ça quelques
tirs en tant que ça s'est pas produit
pour moi ça sera une très grande
satisfaction alors émis porter lève les
yeux je rappellerai à nicolas conc'air
que ces éléments de langage des
républicains qui ne cesse de répéter que
toutes les villes démocrates sont à feu
et à sang il ya des émeutes la semaine
dernière on a arrêté la personne qui a
tiré sur le bureau de poste de bureau de
police a mis en place pendant les
manifestations
cet homme qui a crié justice pour
georges floyd c'était l'équivalent des
black blocks en france c'était quelqu'un
de l'extrême droite
des boucles aux boys qui venait du texas
avec son arme pour venir s'en mêler aux
manifestations pacifiques et essayer de
donner cette impression que c'était les
gens
des blacks l'animateur qui faisait
violence c'est faux c'est archi faux et
c'est prouvé maintenant et cette
histoire de loi et de l'ordre que trump
serait le président de l'organe order
comme avait dit nixon d'ailleurs pas sûr
que ça soit un exemple byden a déjà
évidemment condamné toutes les violences
qui a pu avoir
et pour trump qui dit que la loi est
très importante
lui qui attend le 20 janvier une armée
d'avocats qui vont de mettre en examen
pour la fraude fiscale la fraude
bancaire et la fraude à l'assurance
il pourrait commencer par suivre les
lois lui même avant de nous parler à
nous de ce qu'il faudrait faire
c'est bon c'est vrai que vous parlez de
parler du mini de table et on parlait
aussi des c'est vrai que l'élection elle
s'est joué beaucoup en 2016 dans les
summer est dans les faubourgs elle va se
jouer aussi là peut-être un nez un
éclairage sur un mot qu'on entend qui
s'appelle le blended c'est-à-dire blacks
exit c'est à dire un certain nombre de
devoirs qui passe du camp démocrate au
camp républicain même si c'est
relativement faible à mon avis un amour
rapide nicolas bancaire parce que et il
faut qu'on avance un petit peu noir
c'est plus beaucoup c'est exactement
donc c'est une excellente initiative
lancée par cette jeune north america
american pie et quand des ong américaine
elle a initié ce mouvement pour
justement faire prendre conscience à ces
minorités afro américaine qu'elle avait
toujours été instrumentalisé par le
parti démocrate et qu'il utilisait
uniquement comme s'il était dépositaire
de leurs votes
ce qui est vraiment une manière voilà de
leur dire mais qu'ont fait les
démocrates pour vous depuis toutes ces
années
tournez vous vers le parti républicain
qui voit là des résultats parlent d'eux
mêmes le taux le taux de chômage auprès
des communautés afroaméricaine n'a
jamais été aussi bas pour les latinos
identique allemand et du coup voilà
l'idée c'est il faut quitter la
plantation démocrate le parti démocrate
qui lui a dit historique de l' esclavage
historique des lois de ségrégation de
jim crow et du coup c'est un mouvement
qui a pris de l'ampleur et qui montre
qu' il faut arrêter de juste capter tout
un électorat sur la base d'une couleur
de peau c'est c'est l'essai technique
démocrate vraiment indigéniste ou bastia
listes sont caducs et ils vont avoir des
mauvaises surprises
que ce soit dans des pays comme des
états comme la pennsylvanie autres dans
lesquelles les électorats noir vont
vraiment se mobiliser en faveur du parti
de ma public le week end en onomo
l'électorat noir c'est quoi c'est à peu
près 80% démocrate non ça dépend des
élections mais globalement c'est entre
85 et 95 % les femmes est plus marquée
que les hommes donc en fait le message
républicain s'adresse plutôt aux hommes
et s'adresse pas en fait aux hommes pour
voter républicain c'est pour ne pas
voter et en fait ce qu'on a vu dans des
coins comme détroit où ou milwaukee
c'est que entre 2012 et 2016
on voit une déperdition pour le
démocrate pas forcément un bien pour les
républicains
les gens qui votaient démocrate dans des
contexte plutôt noir qui ne votent pas
et donc on voit en fait la courbe qui
s'infléchit assez nettement et ça suffit
en fait aux républicains à passer
légèrement devant en réalité on voyait
déjà cet affaissement dans certains
endroits pas partout entre 2008 et 2012
c'est à dire des gens qui avaient voté
pour obama qui avait été déçu par obama
donc ce n'est pas forcément un 2012 2016
c'est plutôt 2008 2016 là ce qu'on voit
c'est quand même une sur mobilisation
des thés noirs en revanche sur chez les
hispaniques qui a une résonance du
message de trump mais surtout du message
républicain c'est-à-dire que les
hispaniques peuvent être tentés
notamment les hispaniques de troisième
génération qui sont des chefs
d'entreprises etc peuvent être tentés
par le message n'ont pas de très près le
message républicain
ceux qui sont conservateurs religieux
sont intentés également par un message
conservateur religieux et donc hostile à
l'avortement ce genre de choses et enfin
ceux qui sont des immigrés légaux qui
sont passés par l'espèce de parcours du
combat
l'immigration légale eux ils ont beau
être hispanique
ils sont pas pour ouvrir les portes de
l'immigration illégale le saut pour que
les gens suivent le processus légal
d'immigration c'est pour ça qu'on voit
une tentation républicaine chez les
hispaniques qui est nettement plus
prononcée au nettement moins rare que
chez les noirs dans ce cas c'est
résiduelles et ça ça témoigne beaucoup
plus de nu de la stratégie de campagne
mais qui va forcément très très marquée
en revanche qui peut être marqué par une
forme de non pas de transfert vers l'est
républicain comme on le voit avec les
hispaniques mais deux d'abstention au
fond est ce que cette élection va pas se
résumer aux autres c'est un référendum
pro ou en titres alors il ya un
journaliste français qui en 2016 a
publié un livre c'est peut-être un peu
les raisons de la colère c'est c'est
andré bercoff je vous propose d'écouter
on va leur coûter un petit extrait de
l'interview de ces fêtes de lui et puis
vous allez réagir
andré bercoff bonjour vous êtes
journaliste vous être essayiste est à la
tête d'une émission qui a beaucoup de
succès sur sud radio et surtout vous
avez publiée il ya quatre ans et d'air
avant l'élection de donald trump un
livre il s'appelait trimpe les raisons
de la colère et vous étiez un des rares
observateurs peut-être l'un des seuls le
seul à penser qu'il avait et qu'ils
pouvaient emporter l'élection contre
hillary clinton
alors est-ce que quatre ans plus tard
vous fait le même pari est ce que selon
vous
trump a encore des chances de remporter
l'élection contre 2 maiden alors en
dépit des sondages effectivement
pourquoi qui s'accumulent qui se
multiplient je pense d'abord bat risque
s'il n'y avait pas eu copie
ce jeu vous aurez fait un pari oui un
très grand paris en 10 ans que avec un
résultat économique notamment qu'il
avait eue et y compris on n'a pas parlé
hier au débat entre train b byden en
politique étrangère je pense qu'il avait
de très fortes chances
je pense qu'il ya toujours des chances
peut-être ce sera beaucoup plus serré
que cela aurait été à voir lakovic 19
mais je pense qu'il a vraiment des
chances parce que on l'a vu encore au
débat et il ya une espèce de d'énergie
chez lui tire plaît aux américains pas
seulement pour le côté baba noces ouest
au western et compagnie c'est parce
qu'il a effectivement c'est un
pragmatique c'est pas du toit ni de log
il a obtenu quand même s attende de
résultat et je pense qu'il a vraiment
les chances et surtout surtout alors je
ne sais pas est un stade ça va jouer
mais honnêtement parce qu'on ait
beaucoup de choses là dessus ce qui se
passe autour de la famille by dell
risque quand même de poser pas
complètement mais assez fortement dans
les prochains jours donc comme comme ça
avait pesé sur hillary clinton
d'ailleurs en 2016 mais justement vous
parlez de ce dernier débat c'est de
celui qui a eu lieu jeudi soir
alors il y avait des il y avait une
formule différente puisque ont coupé le
micro et finalement ça plutôt été
favorables comme c'est à dire qu'il l'a
il a peut-être un peu revêtu cette ce
posthume de président barack obama par
exemple heureux leur reproche de ne pas
l'avoir fait plus tôt
oui c'est très vrai ses délires que je
pense je ne sais pas si c'est
effectivement le micro qu'il avantage et
il faut bien dire qu'après mais on l'a
remarqué la modératrice du débat qui est
une démocrate a beaucoup plus interrompu
le train que manuellement ça c'est du
détail
ce qu'il ya c'est que trump
contrairement au premier débat où il
n'était pas bon où il s'était laissé
aller et garder son sang froid
surtout il a eu deux arguments honnête
voire très fort c'est incontestable que
l'ordinateur de fils by dell et ceux qui
l'un des revenus là dessus sur les pays
morts but qui traînent gilles évidemment
ça qu'apple légèrement et même plus que
légèrement déstabilisé un maiden et puis
il lui a dit ça de façon très répéter
c'était évidemment un argument politique
mais il a joué l'hymne arfa vous avez
été huit ans au pouvoir
qu'est ce que vous avez fait pendant
huit ans vous dites oh je vais faire ça
et ça y est ça hebbadj qui est étonnant
n'a pas répondu parce qu'il y aurait
plus répondrai pas des alizés que vous
avez très bien que vice président c'est
un ministre c'est pas être réglé par
rapport à maquereau le vice président
américain
dacca rôle je dirais décoratives enfin
il peut faire des choses mais il est là
pour si le président une défaillance est
là pour le remplacer dont la dette ne
sais pas du tout des raisons évidentes
désolidariser même à un moment donné
d'obama en disant m ai parlé de ça mais
moi je dis pas au pouvoir
c'est barack obama qui est aubois donc
vous avez raison il a été plus
présidentiel est en tout cas qui s'est
posé en disant voilà moi j'ai fait des
choses je vais faire des choses et
surtout regardé j'ai eu locaux vides
je me sens mieux bétail vous voyez très
bien la différence d'énergie entre les
deux débats alors vous avez beaucoup
défendu pendant son mandat contre ce
qu'il traitait de fou contre ceux qui
voulaient le destituer ce contre ceux
qui s'étonnaient de la manière dont ils
mener sa politique avec les nombreux
tweets
mais quand même est ce que cette manière
directives que disruptive comment dire
et de faire de la politique n'est pas
quand même un peu dangereuse regardez il
ya pas une guerre froide qui est en
train de se recréer entre la chine et
des états unis
mais écoutez je ne crois pas je ne crois
pas alors effectivement on pourrait
vraiment lui reprocher ça je trouve pas
ça très très cette politique du tweet à
outrance etc
il faut pas oublier patrice carmouze le
début qu'est ce qui s'est passé en fait
c'est vraiment histoire de l'état
profond vous avez d'ailleurs en france
en amérique et ailleurs plus comme on
veut ou les gens se cooptent ce sont les
ménines de velazquez
on est ensemble au score on se connecte
bulot ce programme et on se retrouve
entre soi voilà quelqu'un qui évidemment
était milliardaire et c'est là mais qui
n'étaient pas dans l'antre soi et dont
la lutte a été que allez on va aller sur
l'état profond c'est le fameux dips tête
et on va essayer de discuter il
affective à une politique disruptive et
comme il avait faut bien se rappeler
même avant son élection de 2016 là les
quatre cinquièmes des médias
l'establishement des politiques qui
contre elle à munich 1 contre lui sa
seule manière était de casser le code a
déserté médian par les réseaux sociaux
etc faire directement du producteur au
consommateur qu'est ce qui s'est passé
il avait ça et si on regarde que ce sont
les 10 et moins cher y compris avec la
chine qu'est-ce qui fait lui pratiquer
la politique du deal
car jeudi le deal au sens des gosses
yater du terme c'est à dire je montre je
montre mes muscles
je vais juste peut-être jusqu'à la
limite et puis et puis je négocie avec
la chine
qu'est ce qui s'est passé il a poussé
les terribles importe exporte la chine
veut rentrer comme dans du beurre aux
états unis les produits chinois et il
n'y avait pas de taxes effectivement
réciproque
il a fait ça la corée du nord il a quand
même on dit on rappelez vous qu'on
disait un moment donné c'est le fou
qu'ils ont coulé trup ça va être la
guerre nucléaire ça va être terrible
bon je ne dis pas que ça va sur la
mouche mais en fait on peut pas dire
qu'il ya une guerre nucléaire regarder
ce qui se passe au moyen orient
regardez vers lui et avec l'iran sa
tactique sa stratégie c'est de lire moi
je négocie en permanence et puis bien il
faut bien dire que pour le moment
heureusement il n'ya pas eu de guerre
déclenchée par lui lui il est temps que
le vois je rappelle cette harrag matic
ce n'est pas un idéologue ou bien voir
ça alors
je veux parler de votre livre d'il ya
quatre ans trempe les raisons de la
colère votre dernier livre s'appelle le
retour des peuples est-ce que d'une
certaine façon propre ses troupes c'est
le symbole ou l'incarnation de ce retour
des peuples je crois que c'est un des
symboles c'est ça qui est très
intéressant voilà quelqu'un qui vous
avez un bon multimilliardaire et j'ai
assisté à d'autres c'est mythique en
2016 quand j'étais là-bas je suis allé à
doute ses meetings et justement le
problème de deux des médias trop souvent
c'est qu'il reste entre new york et los
angeles côte ouest et qu'au test en
amérique c'est pas possible c'est
l'amérique profonde comme la france ou
périphériques ont parlé christophe
guilluy c'est pas que paris marseille et
voilà et donc ce qui m'a frappé c'est
que je me suis demandé comme vous je
l'interrogé les gens meeting comme ça
mais personne dans un stade de football
et je vais vous gagnez combine un l'âme
disait 1000 $ de 1000 $ et ça j'y allais
je comprends pas vous suivez un
multimilliardaire ml mais justement
c'est parce qu'il est riche pour le
suisse fume pourquoi dis parce que lui
ne risque t'il être achetés vendus ça
jouer c'est à dire que les gens se sont
dit il parle pour nous à doha raison
après on peut en discuter mais il n'est
pas de l'establishment
il n'est pas de ces délits rappelez vous
qu'est ce qui s'est passé c'est qu'on
n'a jamais lucerne à l'histoire des amis
en france et aux états unis que dès le
début la destruction c'est à dire il
fallait le destituer il fallait empêcher
les frais lui d'abord on n'a pas réussi
il valait le destituer rappelé boule
bleue müller sur tous les jours tous les
jours ensuite le cren et sert à la
russie la collusion les rapports ceci
rappant cela dès le km une espèce de
monter le lever le bouclier contre lui
qui n'est pas inutile donc observer
c'est le facteur humain je crois que le
facteur humain et l'histoire jouent
beaucoup bien sûr que l'économie joue
bien sûr que l'histoire joue mais faut
pas oublier que le facteur humain
la personne qui a l'énergie se battre eh
ben elle peut aller assez loin qu'il
nous donnait un kopeck sur son élection
en 2016 et aujourd'hui tous les sondages
le donnent
on verra on verra merci infiniment andré
bercoff rappelle le votre dernier livre
s'appelle donc le retour des peuples
merci beaucoup merci
on verra bien même les plus forts
soutiens de troy en règle dans le doute
à votre avis de l'élection et les jouets
elle me porter ou pas aucune élection
n'est jamais joué aux états unis on
regarde beaucoup les sondages mais comme
je dis souvent les sondages ne votent
pas donc tout va être question de la
mobilisation de l'affluence qui va
vraiment se déplacer pour voter soit par
correspondance soit dans les bureaux de
vote
et pour moi la base de train se réduit
de jour en jour à cause des changements
démographiques tout simplement aux états
unis en 1975 les hommes blancs sans
diplôme représenté 71% de la population
aujourd'hui ne sont plus que 39 % le
reste de la population ce sont des gens
diplômés et les gens de couleur 61% et
surtout les femmes
il ya beaucoup de femmes blanches qui on
veut tpo train en 2016 séduite un peu
par cette image qu'il avait et manon
c'est pas ça c'est qu'ils jouent et un
businessman là à la télévision pendant
14 ans avec son émission et les gens on
pensait que c'était vrai il pensait
qu'il était vraiment un businessman
maintenant on sait que c'est faux on
regarde les articles du new york times
qui montrent que toutes ces propriétés
tous ces hôtels perte de l'agencé un
piètre businessman et l'ain depuis
quatre ans c'est pareil il est en
représentation ils jouent à être
président il aime bien venir devant les
caméras mais ne gouverne pas il ne
préside rien du tout et je pense qu'il
ya surtout une partie des électeurs ou
aux états unis sans les électrices les
femmes sont dans une espèce de rage
incandescente depuis quatre ans à cause
de la politique qui la met en place déjà
de sa misogynie sa façon de traiter les
femmes journalistes surtout il est il
est
illégaux gens il n'ya pas d'autre mot
quand il est face à elle la tout ce
qu'il essaie de faire pour le droit à
l'avortement et surtout surtout cette
politique de séparation des enfants de
leur famille il y encore 545 enfants aux
etats unis l'administration trump a
avoué ils ne savent pas où sont leurs
parents les parents ont été déportés
sans rentrer dans l'endurance et au
venezuela et les enfants sont là et
livrés à eux-mêmes et trump a dit
pendant des bas mais ils sont très très
bien traités ils sont ils sont dans des
bonnes conditions
on préfère ne pas être dans un hôtel
cinq étoiles mais être avec ses parents
vous allez aux basques de rester plutôt
nicolas conquérants en deux mots les
raisons de voter trump pour vous
concrètement là le choix de cette
élection qui nous est offerte il est pas
de voter démocrate ou républicain il est
vraiment de voter pour l'avenir des
états unis avec la possibilité de
continuer sur cette impulsion de revoir
la réforme toute la bureaucratie et de
relancer l'économie de faire aspirer et
de continuer à incarner ce raid
américain et les textes et les libertés
fondamentales qui sont exposées dans la
constitution ou vient de sombrer dans un
bain dans un chaos qui nous est monté
par un parent du démocrate a voté
toujours plus de projets toujours plus
de taxes qui va vraiment constituent
vraiment mettre à l'économie à plat et
voilà offrir un futur qui sera vraiment
vraiment sombre pour les états unis
lorie kane tôt pour conclure là on parle
beaucoup du risque de blocage
vous y croyez le blocage toute façon le
voit depuis avant trump le blocage il
existe au congrès depuis depuis au moins
2010 avec l'arrivée de mitch mcconnell à
la tête du sénat en 2014 avant trump on
à de l'obstruction et de
l'obstructionnisme total c'est à dire
que le losc veut mitch mcconnell de
trump à côté c'est un enfant de coeur
qu'on se trompe de problème une certaine
manière
mitch mcconnell c'est le blocage total
de tout ce qui ressemble de près ou de
loin une politique démocrate ya plus de
politique bipartisane le blocage il est
déjà là
qu'on va avoir c'est des gens qui d'un
côté ou de l'autre peut-être plus d'un
côté que de l'autre refuse la légitimité
du résultat de l'élection
on est encore loin de savoir comment ce
résultat va se cristalliser est ce qu'on
sait pas combien de temps ça va prendre
on va avoir des tas de recours etc et au
final on aura un résultat le problème
c'est que des deux côtés et peut-être
d'un côté plus que de l'autre on va
avoir un refus de la légitimité du
résultat et dès l'instant où on a des
gars sur des pick up avec décalage qui
commence à s'exciter
on sait pas trop où ça peut terminer on
a eu oklahoma city 95 il ya 25 ans parce
que des gens trouvaient que l'état
l'état fédéral s'était en 170 morts plus
tard on est vraiment c'est pas exclure
tout ça très bien mais c'est sur ces
mots qu'on va se conclure on se
retrouvera peut-être après le après le 3
novembre pour pourparlers la situation
savoir si joe biden d'été lui ici c'est
vraiment lui qui va gouverner ou kamala
harris ou peut-être obama la dose parce
qu'il est quand même un peu âgés s'y
tromper réélu comment comment tout ça va
se passer
merci en tout cas à vous tous merci
unies porteur merci nicolas conquet
merci le reagan dont je rappelle le
votre livre le rêve américain à
l'épreuve de donald trump c'est aux
éditions vendémiaire et bercy beaucoup
nicolas landry et à très vite pour un
nouveau numéro de poste
[Musique]